hello everyone it's a pleasure
to be here uh i'm jay hoing chief
scientist at advanced solutions life
sciences
and i want to talk to you today about
our work in the area of
developing in vitro tissue models
that are vascularized and made entirely
from human constituents
so here at advanced solutions we focus
on really two types of in vitro models
one is modeling tissues
derived from cell systems and
combinations that give us the outcome
that we want
as well as combining then these tissue
systems into more complex
more organ-like or chaining them
together into
looking at physiology and as a reminder
remember that organs such as the heart
shown here in the left
are made from tissues tissues
of which there may be multiple tissue
types building contributing to that
organ
but each tissue then is made up of a
variety of constituents
including different cell types whether
it's in cases of myocardium here
cardiomyocytes cardio fibroblasts
the microvasculature uh particularly in
the more distal ends of the tissue bed
as well as immune cells
and then the cells then of course make
up the tissues the tissues make up the
organs and then
organs together make up a more complete
whole body physiology
and today the focus is going to be on
the tissue modeling efforts that we have
going on here
and primarily emphasizing our efforts to
bring in
a micro vasculature into those tissue
models
as a reminder the the micro vasculature
is an integral part of any tissue or
nearly any tissue cartilage for example
is
relatively vascular for many parts of it
it's necessary for tissue homeostasis
as well as tissue function of course is
serving as a conduit for blood
and perfusion that not only gives
nutrient
gas exchange but also inter tissue
or an inter-organ communication
as signals and hormones for example are
moving from one
tissue bed to another and of course the
vascular serves as the gatekeeper there
between the blood space and the tissue
space for example
immune cells moving through the blood
moving into different
specific tissue beds and what we're
learning also in our modeling
as well as others in their research
efforts is that
the constituents the cells of the tissue
or the vasculature
communicate in a cooperative fashion
with the cells of the tissue whether
it's the strum on the franklin as we get
further in
i'll give some examples of where we're
seeing that in some of our tissue models
one other aspect i think that's
important when it comes to tissue
modeling and it'll it'll show up
again in some of the models that i'll
discuss here
is that the vasculature will take on
tissue specific phenotype so-called
organotypic function
such that perhaps there's a continuous
capillary bed in muscle and in brain for
example where there's good segregation
between blood and tissue space
or as we move into endocrine organs
where we want good hormone
exchange between the tissue and the
blood space
there might be a fenestrated capillary
bed and then
perhaps free exchange of plasma
constitutes with the tissue interstitium
such as you see in liver and with the
sinusoidal
so uh always in building these tissue
models we pay attention to is the
vasculature taking on the
characteristics of that specific tissue
bed
and we think that's critical for that
tissue function
it's also important to recognize that
within the vasculature we have multiple
vessel types
not only in phenotypes as i mentioned
with the continuous discontinuous
fenestrated sinusoidal
but also in the makeup of those vessels
and whether we're inflow the arterial
exchange the capillary outflow the
venule
as well as all the different cell types
not only the different endothelium of
which can vary depending on where you
are in the vascular tree but also those
cells
that constitute the micro vessel wall
and that cellular heterogeneity we feel
is really important
in allowing the vasculature to take on
these organotypic features
to adapt and remodel and fit the
function of the tissue
and matching then the vascular needs
and finally no one single micro vessel
say a capillary really functions alone
unlike an artery where it operates as a
single large conduit
if we take that artery out for example
there's serious complications downstream
but if you take out a capillary
no real consequence and that's because
it's really the microvasculature exists
as a network a system of micro vessel
segments that are interconnected in a
very hierarchical nature
and importantly it can be self assembled
uh
as well as adaptive as it's responding
to those tissue cues
and we always like to think of the
microvasculature as a cell system or a
tissue in it of itself
so reality we're talking about the
myocardium where we have cardiomyocytes
and starting to build muscle sheets
and build that cardiac tissue we
actually have a microvascular tissue
that's part of that so really more of a
tissue assembly when we think of these
larger tissue beds
that then contribute to the organ
function
our solution is to leverage what mother
nature uses
and that is whole but fragmented pieces
of
individual microvessels so unlike
starting with
individual vascular cells which we did
some years ago
and had some success but struggled in
other applications
we went to a different route where
instead of going to single cells we go
down to the level of the whole micro
vessel and then
work with those and enable those to
create that new microvascular bed
we use adipose in the left here is an
image of that where the adipocytes the
fat containing cells are red
the vasculature is green strip way the
adipocytes leaving behind that
microvascular network break that network
up into small pieces
shown here in the middle panel and
importantly those small pieces
retain all the cells that normally
reside in the microvascular wall
which further analysis has showed us
that that can be considerable
uh not only do you have the endothelial
cells and the smooth muscle and the
perivascular kind of vessel wall cells
but we also have
evidence of progenitor cells stem cells
and
including a significant proportion of
tissue resonant macrophages we think all
of these are important to not only
building a vasculature but also in
in driving that tissue homeostasis uh
where the vasculature is contributing to
really
a moderation and a mediator of some of
those activities that go on
in that tissue bed uh
importantly if you take those micro
vessel segments
and embed them in a three-dimensional
tissue environment here
green collagen fibrils and then the red
micro vessels are
are are growing you'll see these new
vessel segments that grow out
via angiogenesis they'll change
direction and they'll actually find each
other
and connect and start to form this
neovascular network
it's a dynamic system it's a messy
system
in the video playing here perhaps you
see a variety of different cell types
that are moving around again we think
all of those are important
to help start reconstituting as much of
that tissue stroma as possible
once grown up if you then implant these
so if i start with my
vessel isolates i grow them up into a
neovasculature and i
implant them in a variety of positions
so we've looked at
you know peritoneal kidney capsule
as well as sub-q we can derive a more
stereotypical micro-circulation it was a
good hierarchical organization
inflow outflow paths and all of this
evolves from that initial
neovasculture and that really i think
reflects that adaptation and plasticity
of the system
and we let the tissue environment
dictate the outcomes of the vessel and
vasculature and microcirculation type
so in the process of doing these
experiments so
we we uncovered this organotypic
plasticity
such that if we in this particular case
which we published
some years ago take our fat micro vessel
pieces
combine them with cells that help
establish the blood-brain barrier a very
tight permeability barrier in the brain
those cell types are the astrocytes and
we use the precursor of the astrocyte
which we call grp
if you combine those grps with our fat
vessels
in that 3d matrix environment that i
just showed in the video
and plant those subcutaneously it
it will evolve in forms of
microcirculation that becomes more
blood-brain barrier-like so in the
middle panel there on
on the right half uh our fat vessels
start to express
up regulate the glute one transporter
it's a hallmark feature of the
blood-brain barrier
and uh starts to show more restrictive
permeability
than the fat vessels alone in that sub-q
position
and so we're starting to see this kind
of parenchymal
uh microvessel communication and
cooperativity
such that the vessels take on a
tissue-specific phenotype and i'll show
you another
example or two as we go on
with that in mind then i'd like to take
you through some of the models that
we've developed
to explain a little bit how we're doing
it and then describing some of the
biology that's going on
again emphasizing the role of the
baskets are in that
uh you know at advanced solutions we're
involved in
in building therapeutic tissues in
addition to the tissue models and then
of course
uh more more streamlined assays for
particular vascular related functions
but in all cases our strategy is is to
modulate
the environment such that enables the
parenchyma
and the vasculature to to assemble and
form a nice cohesive tissue environment
we build these tissue models in these
therapeutic tissues
using our bioassembly tissue fabrication
platform
i'm just going to give one slide on this
but to highlight that this is a
our single uh robotic-based tissue
fabrication platform where we have
design
software working and communicating with
the robotic arm
to do everything from bioprinting to
tissue assemblies to pipetting whatever
is needed to build those tissues
and really take a design and make
strategy
with our second set of software called
bio apps that
allows this one single platform which is
agile and flexible to build a variety of
different
tissue types so with this platform and
our isolated micro vessel approach this
is where we really started to explore
and develop those strategies and
protocols for building these tissue
models
and one such model is our thick
vascularized human liver tissue model
we set out to really to create a liver
tissue environment such that we can look
at
cell migration say for cell or immune
cell dynamics moving through a tissue
space
or perhaps house a hepatocellular
tumor that might sit within a you know
quote-unquote normalized tissue
environment
these are about a one centimeter thick
we use a bioprinting strategy to
structure that tissue
such that we get minimal necrosis and
and good media tissue exchange of course
we have our vasculature in there
uh we see good tissue function uh i've
shown here up to seven days we've seen
this out to two weeks
uh 14 days we're finding that having the
micro vessels present enables us to go
to this thicker tissue environment and
to scale it out to the larger
tissue volumes in general there in the
upper left is
a 12 well example of our of our liver
tissue
and interesting where we're seeing our
micro vessels player roles not so much
in base functions such as urea
production but
in cytochrome 450 up regulation as well
as
bio salt transporter up regulation
etc so really our vessels seem to be
adding to the refined functionality of
the tissue in addition to
enabling this thicker tissue environment
another example here is our vascularized
eyelid models
we're really looking at it in two ways
one is again this thick tissue approach
that we did with the liver
or in this case using derived beta cells
we're working with the partner
dr ipshita banerjee at the university of
pittsburgh she's deriving these beta
cells from stem cells
and she's creating spheroids in her
particular application and we got
together
because she initially attempted to build
a vasculature in these spheroids using
isolated endothelial cells and struggled
and so we've been able to working
closely devised
a new strategy such as we can stage the
fabrication of the spheroid
and get our micro vessels into the
spheroid and then they undergo
angiogenesis and really expand it
and we were pleasantly surprised to see
that not only can we get that
vasculature established
which by the way has implications if we
want to start transplanting these
but the vessels themselves improve beta
cell responsiveness to glucose such as
in a glucose challenge we see this nice
spike in insulin release
and then a return back to a baseline uh
without the micro vessels the beta cells
completely deplete their insulin source
and have to then be recharged with the
vessels
there's more of a balanced response and
one that you see more in the tissue bed
and interestingly we start to see our
fat vessels express
more of that fenestrated endurican like
uh
organotypic vasculature that you see in
the pancreas and then islets
and so this is our you know first
example here of that cooperativity where
our vessels are responding to the beta
cells
as well as the beta cells responding to
the vessel present
and this is a recent paper it's
impressed
just got it in the journal
biofabrication
where we're looking to build adipose
organoids
for use in adipose inflammation and
insulin resistance studies
all related to type 2 diabetes
and and here we're deriving the
adipocytes from mesenchymal stem cells
and again developed a strategy to
integrate our vasculature
in the middle upper panel there
you see this nice red star burst of
vessels that
were formed in the spheroid we place
that spheroid into a collagen
environment
again in vitro and we have this nice
robust angiogenic burst
outside of that so we know that our
vessels not only are there but they're
functional
and again this has implications if we
want to tie this into other types of
tissue models or
perhaps pursue a therapeutic
interestingly
uh while baseline adipocyte functions
such as lipolysis
is good but not really affected by the
vessels that are present
the vessels in themselves induce the
adipocytes to upregulate the insulin
receptor which obviously is important in
not only glucose metabolism and fat
function but
sets the stage for an insulin resistance
modeling
so again here we see this nice dynamic
response
of the of the adipose organoids to
certain challenges
as well as some new features when we
again start to reconstitute that tissue
environment more
with our microvasculature
in all cases we've been exploring the
utility of
through tissue perfusion uh in this
particular example it's with our thick
liver construct
using our uh our bioassembly platform
we're 3d printing up sacrificial
networks
and assembling our thick tissue around
those channels
and then using a an office or a
customized
system that works with off-the-shelf
plastic such as multi-well plates
uh that we've developed in-house we can
really start to provide perfusion
through that tissue bed
where the channels themselves are formed
by the tissue and so
this gives us as added flexibility we're
certainly seeing the
changes that perfusion introduces not
only just in survival but in some
functional differences
as well and so um i'll speak a little
bit later about
complexity but our particular approach
has been designed to give flexibility on
on how you assemble the model depending
on
what types of questions you want to
answer and what your objectives are
finally while originally i
talked to you about how we can get our
micro vessels to form a neovasculture in
vitro
you can take that and plant it in vivo
say under the skin of a
immune compromised mouse and have that
connect inoculate to the whole
circulation and drive
the formation of a new microcirculation
but we wanted to recapitulate that full
process
in vitro and so um what i'm showing you
here is our
in vitro human microcirculation we're
getting ready to assemble this and put
this
in of to review for publication
but we're combining our microvessel
technology
uh brand name angiomix
with a microfluidic channel system such
that we have and then the upper right
perhaps is the best
schematic of that where we have
microfluidic channels that we
then grow uh adjacent
a neovasculture from our isolated micro
vessels similar what i've been talking
about so far
and inducing them to to connect or
inosculate with the channel walls that
have been aligned with endothelial cells
and form a network and then start to via
intravascular perfusion and controlling
hemodynamic cues
drive and mature that microcirculation
and so on the images here on the left
the upper left
corner is is our endothelial saw line
channel
on the lower left is a neovasculature
that's grown up here's shown in red
fluorescence
in the middle are phase images where the
two arrows
open arrows highlight the walls of the
channel and and adjacent to that
is a is a network of micro vessels that
are formed the arrows are pointing to
some and not certainly not all
the next adjacent panel is showing that
inosculation event between
our microvessel from that network to
that channel wall and the right are
stills from a video
where we've introduced beads into the
channels and then we're observing those
beads
moving in through the different vessel
elements of that micro circulation
and so we're like i mentioned with the
process of finalizing this body of work
putting it out there for review and then
uh
getting input on what people think
obviously there's a lot of implications
both
both in therapeutics but now also we're
starting to think
how can we combine our other previous
models such as our adipocyte model
with the islet model and start to really
create
a more complex physiological system
where each of these model systems are
connected via bonafide microcirculation
and really start to recapitulate as much
of that in body
tissue environment and physiology as we
possibly can
so with that uh summarize a little bit
what i've been talking about here
with you one is
so you know the idea of recapitulating a
tissue in vitro
uh recognizing full well that those
tissues are complex and varied
um typically when you start combining
different components into the
into a tissue-like environment you start
to see emergent behaviors you start to
see
kind of a greater than the sum of the
parts type behavior
and that's primarily due to that high
integration and dynamics so our
our modeling strategy is such that we
enable those dynamics to play themselves
out
uh of course you know we emphasize uh we
have expertise in this uh
that of course then a bias in the need
to have a micro vasculature in the
tissue it's
we think it's a critical element with or
without perfusion we're seeing evidence
that the micro vessels present
contribute to good tissue model behavior
we also know that the vasculature
participates in the disease
process we've not explored much of that
yet we're just starting to do that now
that these models are in place
uh and and we've gained the appreciation
that they're
they really serve the microvascular and
those elements of the microvasculature
serve as a
reservoir for stromal cells in
particular we're paying attention to
tissue resident macrophages
we think that's key and all of that
really is starting to
realize that microvessel parenchyma
cooperativity
that we just weren't seeing with
endothelial cells alone some cases we
were but not in all
and so we're really pleased that we're
able to
advance this a bit further with our
isolated micro vessels
i went through a handful of models uh
where we're building human vascularized
tissues uh oneness that's the liver
tissue model without
flow through perfusion uh modeling the
eyelid there in the context of an eyelid
organoid
uh this really where we have a good
evidence of vessel
parenchyma cooperativity um of course
our modeling uh adipose inflammation and
insulin resistance with our adipose
organoid
uh and finally uh we're really excited
about our in vitro microcirculation
model which originally set out we set
out to model
tissue vascularization but obviously we
have an opportunity now to start to
model a lot of other different
biologies as well as physiologies
and with respect to strategies on that
we take to build these models
we don't always necessarily try to
recapitulate a complete tissue but
those aspects of the tissue we're most
interested in
so perhaps it's cell cell interaction
maybe it's a dermal
subdermal dynamics that we want to see
in the skin
or cellular composition experimentally
wants to reconstitute in different
ratios or different cellular elements to
understand the biology
or compartmentalization having a blood
space
that an immune cell can leave and enter
into a tissue space
or perhaps a tumor cell leaving its
primary tumor and then moving in and
metastasizing out into a lymphatic space
you know all that represents a lot of
different dynamics that are relevant to
health and disease
and even looking at biomechanics where
we're altering tissue boundary
conditions
to see what the effects are on and
internal uh
stress and strain dynamics uh and
uh you know we we're agnostic to the
fabrication approach our
fabrication by assembly platform
really is agile lets us accommodate a
different a number of different
strategies whether it's bioprinting as i
mentioned
or organoid formation that we then can
assemble into larger
constructs but
you know what's the biology you want to
model what's the best way to
assemble that system and how do you best
you implement that and really we walk
through that kind of uh
strategy uh routinely uh and
uh you know obviously how complex you
want to make it how complex are you able
to make it it certainly
comes in and plays a key role but
ultimately
i think our goal is to start to assemble
these multiple different tissue types to
capture more and more of the whole body
physiology and with that i very much
appreciate your time
and i would love to answer or entertain
and answer
any of your questions thank you